just had an incredible ecommerce meeting
here on a Saturday as you guys know I
don't usually work on Saturday but I'm
here for all-star weekend in Los Angeles
the weather is [ __ ] phenomenal not to
go to Baron Davis's event I think I'm
going to rip it up pretty good for the
NBA players and just living the dream
putting the pieces together ecommerce
selling stuff it's good it's [ __ ]
good what's up I do Gary yeah oh you're
Gary Vee I am whoa nice that's sick I
can't I make your vlog yeah of course
what's your name sir oily oily what are
you into sneakers you flip them yeah my
guy what's the best flip you've had I'm
obviously pretty new yep yeah so well
you have to do you have a flip yet or
not yet yeah so you're an aspiring
flipper there's a big difference between
doing and aspiring to he doesn't flip
kicks he aspires to so slurry get your
[ __ ] together
[Music]
yeah about I have no idea what or how
about what she you ready drink this is
the way this is the way I do it yeah
let's go right through that's trick in
the game how are you feeling good crazy
feeling yes it's amazing climbing down
mountains yeah with a lovely I mean the
roller-coaster everything it's a real
pleasure thanks it's been really fun
getting to know your family the crew
I've seen I face time with your mom
thank you thank you I love him back I
just told him you smell great
I can phrase this it's just that you
know like I've been trying to I mean as
a fan of a trying to win a ring since 82
this guy gets a quick little trade and
he picks one up yeah man I worked out
nice yeah but you know what luck of the
draw up that part but a whole lot of
[ __ ] [ __ ] a whole lot of [ __ ]
hard work you know I wish people
understood how hard Pitts athletes work
they don't get it yeah man it takes so
much you guys get work in this week yeah
there's a lot going on
all sort la how are you good work with
Chris on this social initiative want to
get him on your podcast eventually after
the seasons me so good to see you
favorite guy from playing in the end it
went up snapchat t rocket T rocket
motivated me talk about what a baby tell
him that I like thanks so much
yo yo what up Facebook about to speak at
this conference Baron Davis conference
more importantly excited to come on and
talk to you guys about my new first and
line thing it is very very very simple
it is basically a messenger and text
situation where I'm gonna put out jabs
and right hooks it's gonna be
opportunities to get free [ __ ] I've
already got two companies that are
hitting me up with some stuff we're the
first 500 people that fill out the form
boom get it free stuff tons of stuff is
being thrown at me I don't need it or
want it but I want to share it with my
communities so that's what you're gonna
see from first align the opportunity by
first and line stuff like these limited
edition k-swiss there's only 150 pairs
and so people from first in line are
gonna be able to get that first and then
next time I get a facebook beanie I'm
gonna ask for 50 of them boom put them
out in first in line you gotta buy
somebody wanna one hour one hour class
with d-roc to learn how it's done boom
first a lion
on our [ __ ] vrock I'm gonna give it
to em do you rock
yeah good boobs that's what's up that's
how we're doing it first in line first
in line person that's some old school
stuff that's amazing how are you oh god
I just brought back such a flood of good
memories there was literally five blogs
there's like five video shows those were
some days back in the early days when
you could get 5,000 people to show up
with one tweet but those secret wide
parties that I was throwing back then
was more so fun yeah
tiki bar to being the guy with the hat
right keep movin too
don't look at the cases this is the
owner of this job this is a limited
edition that I'm dropping next Wednesday
don't tell them five time baby five
times a good spot I feel like I'm
to answer your question my number one
objective right now in general is to
make good traits alpha so what I'm real
passionate about right now is making
empathy and gratitude and kindness
coolest [ __ ] what there's nobody that
makes it into the league without
sacrificing games and and I think
successful entrepreneurs is the league
there's nobody who's hidden who did it
who got lunches people love people love
excuses you're pulling your [ __ ] the
Internet's changed everything every
excuse coming out of your mouth the
answer is stands because the Internet
has changed everything we have a
calibrated how big is there's no
middleman there's no system there's no
old white dude stopping you go do your
thing this internet thing is real as
[ __ ] and so for me I just think it's the
greatest time to be alive and if you're
not winning during this era of Internet
at scale and [ __ ] nine straight
mirrors of economic growth the new stuff
because how many people under 30 losing
it right right
tons of so one of the things I hate is
that people [ __ ] on Millennials and lazy
they're the same way off everybody's the
same you know lazy people you need
hard-working people hip people
Millennials have so many advantages
under 30 has so many advantages they
actually the only disadvantage I think
they have is they haven't been punched
in the mouth right they haven't lived
through 2008 or 2001 there's a lot of
people in here over 40 who are rich on
paper on Maidan in 2001 2006 and then
the economy got [ __ ] right it's real
cool when you're an Instagram influencer
and making $100,000 and sponsorship
deals until the world melts and those
brands aren't paid so here we are
listen to me I'm going I'm going crazy
right now on Twitter probably post like
17 posts it's the same thing my face red
and all it says and question mark the
level of excuses you know my parents did
this I grew up there their stuff sucks
mine's better debt you know my boss
[ __ ] sucks lead and he's suppressing
me the answer to everything is and like
what are you gonna do about it
and the [ __ ] are you gonna do about it
right sitting and complaining does Jack
[ __ ] [ __ ] and so no matter what you
tell me you email me u DM me you spill
everything I got compassion
I got empathy but after I absorb that
and show you that I care the answer is
always gonna be and the [ __ ] are we
gonna do about it
well you just made a piece cut it think
so too
well I got taken for you yeah you're
coming in so so my big fear right now is
like close be smart be thoughtful like
build something that you can control
like everybody crying about Instagram
and Facebook's algorithm it was free you
built on it for free so they changed it
because the attention of that user is
everything it's what matters and so
they're gonna do what's right for them I
say if you're crying that your organic
beach drop then [ __ ] work start a
[ __ ] podcast [ __ ] start a
newsletter like do something instead of
tryin end up 7,000 likes instead of
11,000 [ __ ] a loser
[Music]